.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wenn alles zusammenbrechen würde ...
Es gibt ja Szenarien wie Bürgerkrieg.
Dann schauen wir, was ist.
- Okay.
Hast du einen Fluchtweg?
- Die Mongolei.
Die Mongolei?
- Mhm.
Die ist 200 km von hier entfernt.
Da kommt man notfalls zu Fuss hin.
Der Schweizer Lukas Achermann wohnt
seit sechs Jahren in Ostsibirien.
Tausende Kilometer weg
von der Ukraine -
und doch irgendwie nahe am Krieg.
Einheimische erzählen,
dass hier oft Flugzeuge landen,
die verletzte Kämpfer von
der ukrainischen Front zurückbringen.
Aber auch der Tod
ist hier allgegenwärtig.
Über 2'000 Kämpfer
aus der Region des Baikalseegebiets
sollen in der Ukraine
bereits gefallen sein.
* Düstere Klänge *
Nur ein paar Autominuten
entfernt vom Friedhof
wird schon die nächste Generation
auf den Krieg vorbereitet.
Militärfreizeitparks wie diesen
gibt es schon seit Längerem.
Doch jetzt kommen neue Helden hinzu.
Ein Denkmal für die Teilnehmer an der
sog. militärischen Spezialoperation.
Schon nur aus dieser Region
zu berichten,
ist schwierig geworden.
Doch Lukas Achermann
will hier weiterleben.
Ich fände es auch
gegenüber der Leute,
mit denen ich befreundet bin,
und gegenüber der Bevölkerung
nicht fair,
aus diesem Grund einfach zu gehen.
Ich stehe auch zu diesen Leuten.
Nur, weil ich die Möglichkeit hätte,
in die Schweiz zu gehen
und weil das für mich
das Bequemste wäre.
Ich solidarisiere mich
ein Stück weit mit ihnen
und zeige,
dass noch jemand hier ist,
der die Hoffnung
nicht verloren hat
und nicht denkt, sie alle
seien Mörder und Schlächter.
Was bedeutet es für den Luzerner -
aber auch für die Einheimischen -,
in einem Land zu leben,
das einen Angriffskrieg führt?
Aha! Salü.
Will er spielen? Hm? Ja, hallo.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Salü, wie geht es?
Gut.
Das hier ist von deiner Schwester.
Aha!
Das hat sie mir für dich mitgegeben.
- Wunderbar, danke vielmals.
Sie meinte, sie und die ganze Familie
seien sehr stolz auf dich.
Das solle ich dir sagen.
- Danke.
"Sibirien lässt niemanden kalt!"
Unter diesem Motto
startete Achermann 2016
seine erste Lastwagenreise
nach Russland -
begleitet von SRF.
In einem
zum Wohnwagen umgebauten Lastwagen
machte er sich auf in Richtung Osten.
Ich habe mir schon in der Kindheit
ausgemalt,
wie ich einst mit dem Lastwagen
quer durch Russland fahren werde -
bis an den Pazifik und zurück.
Das war mein Traum.
Ich habe nachts heimlich unter
der Bettdecke Atlanten angeschaut
und mir eine Strecke ausgedacht,
die ich dann im selbst umgebauten
Lastwagen fahren werde.
Über 8'000 km sind es von Luzern
bis zum Baikalsee.
Diese Reise machte er dann mehrmals
mit Touristen.
2018 übersiedelte er definitiv
nach Sibirien
und liess sich in der Nähe
des grössten Süsswassersees der Welt
nieder.
Zuerst kurz in Irkutsk,
dann in Ulan-Ude,
der Hauptstadt
der russischen Republik Burjatien.
Ja, das ist ...
Ist das deins?
- Das ist meins.
Mein bescheidenes Heim.
- Schön.
Und da wohnt der Nachbar?
- Ja.
Er ist ein Deutscher.
- Ah!
Er wohnt aber auch schon
seit 15 Jahren in Russland.
Er hat eine russische Frau
aus der Gegend, aus Sljudjanka.
Sie haben zwei Kinder.
Sie sind aber
nach Deutschland emigriert.
Sie kommen
nur noch ferienmässig hierher.
Wegen des Kriegs?
- Ja ... V.a. auch wegen der Schule.
Ah, darum?
- Ja.
Es wurde schwierig
mit der Schule hier.- Warum?
Weil es offenbar mehr ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Es wird viel Patriotismus gelehrt.
- Ah, doch.
* Ruhige Musik *
Lukas' ursprüngliches Ziel war,
für Kleinstgruppen ausgiebige
Sibirienreisen im Baikalgebiet
zu organisieren.
Ich machte meistens
zwei- bis dreiwöchige Touren.
Und ...
- Hat das funktioniert?
Ja, es hat funktioniert.
Es war schon immer schwierig,
für Russland Leute zu finden.
Es ist mit so vielen Vorurteilen
behaftet.- Mit Vorurteilen?
Ja. "Russland ist gefährlich."
"Die sind alle besoffen."
"Da hat es nur Mafia."
"Es ist korrupt."
"Man muss um sein Leben fürchten."
"Alles ist grau und furchtbar."
Das stimmt natürlich alles
hinten und vorne nicht.
Die Leute sind extrem nett
und gastfreundlich.
Sie sind zuvorkommend
und haben wirklich Freude,
wenn Europäer kommen -
auch jetzt noch.
Ja.
Auch in der jetzigen Situation.
Ich selber spüre nichts,
keine Ressentiments gegen mich.
Ich spüre keine Repressionen.
Sie können zwischen Politik
und Leuten unterscheiden.
Ah, ein Kamaz.
Natürlich, das ist mein Bubentraum.
Sein Traumfahrzeug
hat er anfangs 2022 gekauft,
nur wenige Tage vor dem
russischen Einmarsch in der Ukraine.
Die Idee war,
daraus ein Wohnmobil zu machen.
Auch wieder für vier Leute.
- Um darin zu schlafen?
Um darin zu leben.
Ich verspürte so eine Euphorie,
als die beschissene Pandemie
endlich durch war.
Ich dachte: "So, jetzt!"
- Ja.
"Jetzt geht es wieder vorwärts."
Und dann kam es noch schlimmer.
- Ja.
Ich habe natürlich nichts gemacht.
Ich habe keinen Franken investiert.
Es bringt ja nichts.
Es kommt eh niemand.
Den europäischen Tourismus
kann man hier
die nächsten 10-15 Jahre vergessen.
Das war's.
Auch wenn es
einen Waffenstillstand gibt?
Sie haben ihr Image
so an die Wand gefahren -
da kommt niemand mehr.
Vielleicht ein paar Einzelpersonen.
- Ja.
Es war ja vorher schon schwierig,
dass überhaupt jemand ...
Dass jemand so weit kam.
Ja, nach Russland
und dann noch nach Sibirien.
Nach Sibirien geht man nicht,
nach Sibirien wird man gebracht.
* Lachen *
Und noch für etwas
ist Sibirien bekannt:
ein schier unendliches Reservoir
an Soldaten.
Die Baikalregion ist -
zusammen mit dem Kaukasus -
einer
der wichtigsten Rekrutierungsorte.
Auch während der Teilmobilmachung.
Ich meine, hier
fand eine Menschenjagd statt.- Ja.
Morgens um 2 Uhr kamen sie,
klopften an und sagten:
"In 30 Min. gehen wir."
- Nein.
Sie suchten die Leute
mit Helikoptern in den Wäldern.
Das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen.
Das weiss ich
von direkt Betroffenen.- Ja.
Da fand eine Menschenhetze statt.
Hey, die haben alle genommen,
die sie gefunden haben.
Darfst du deine Meinung zum Krieg
äussern?
In so einem Film, der in der Schweiz
gezeigt wird?- Nein.
Das will ich auch nicht.
Das Risiko ist mir zu gross.
Wir können heute miterleben,
womit Lukas jetzt sein Geld verdient.
Geplant ist ein Tagesausflug
mit rund zwei Dutzend
sibirischen Seniorinnen,
einer Gruppe,
die sich regelmässig trifft.
Doch zuerst noch
ein obligatorischer Zwischenstopp.
Wir gehen jetzt zur sog. ...
... medizinischen Untersuchung.
Vor jeder Fahrt muss man am Morgen
seine Fahrtauglichkeit
von einem Arzt bestätigen lassen.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Wir drehen seine Reise.
Eine Reise?
So. Wie geht es Ihnen? Blutdruck?
- Es geht mir gut.
150.
- Perfekt?
* Piepsen *
Fertig? Danke. Auf Wiedersehen.
Das hat sie
nur fürs Fernsehen gemacht.
Also, den Puls und die Temperatur
gemessen.
Wird das sonst nicht gemacht?
- Nein, viel zu aufwendig.
Sonst gibt es einen Stempel
und fertig.
Stempel, Unterschrift und fertig.
Ich glaube, sie sieht einem an,
ob man fahrtauglich ist.
Wenn ich mit gläsernen Augen komme
oder ...- Ja.
Dann ...
- Oder nach Alkohol stinkst.
Geht es mehr darum?
- Ja, in erster Linie schon.
Spitzenlöhne
für freiwillige Vertragssoldaten -
solche Werbebanner
trifft man in ganz Russland.
Hallo? Guten Morgen.
- (Frau) Hallo. Hörst du mich?
Guten Morgen. Ich bin gleich
auf dem Parkplatz vor meinem Haus.
Wo bist du jetzt?
Ich bin gleich da.
An verschiedenen Haltestellen
der Stadt Ulan-Ude
sammelt Lukas Seniorinnen auf.
Immer dabei: seine Hündin Stella.
Ich habe für Ihren Hund
Knochen gebracht.
Hier, direkt aus dem Gefrierfach.
Sie sind kalt. Gut?
Ja. Ich habe hier einen Kühlschrank.
Danke vielmals.
Sie braucht doch was
zum Mittagessen.
Sie kommt doch immer mit, oder?
- Ja, genau.
Warum wird gefilmt?
Das sind die
vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Oh, dann werde ich
in der Schweiz gezeigt?
Ja, ja.
Hallo, hallo.
- Wie geht's?
Gut. Liebes,
ich habe dir zu essen mitgebracht.
Kann man das so horizontal hinlegen?
- Ja, kann man.
Guten Tag.
Wir sind
die Delegation aus der Schweiz.
Die Frauen im Bus wollen von mir
wissen, warum Lukas noch ledig sei.
Da muss man sofort alles wissen.
Sie wollten v.a. von dir wissen,
warum du noch ledig seist.
Ja, das ist immer ... Das ist ...
- Das ist das grosse Thema.
Die erste Frage ist immer:
"Warum bist du hier?"
Und die zweite:
"Warum bist du nicht verheiratet?"
"Das gibt's doch nicht,
dass er keine hat!"
Lukas  h a t  eine Partnerin
hier in Ulan-Ude, eine Russin.
Sie arbeite auch im Tourismusbereich.
Bei unserem Besuch war sie allerdings
auf Geschäftsreise.
Immer weitere Frauen kommen hinzu.
Es ähnelt einem Ausflug
in der Schweiz.
Aber die Gespräche -
sie sind vom Krieg geprägt.
Mein Schwiegersohn
wurde von der Front zu
den Untersuchungsbehörden versetzt.
Er wurde ausgezeichnet.
Sein Kumpel hatte auf der Flucht
gegen eine Blechdose mit Sprengstoff
getreten.
Eine Explosion
hat ihm seinen Fuss abgetrennt.
Und unserer hatte eine Kopf-
und eine Knieverletzung.
Man muss aufpassen.
Ja, aber die beiden
wurden ausgezeichnet.
Hundert Tote, neun sind geflohen
und zwei haben überlebt.
Ihr Schwiegersohn
habe jetzt eine Wohnung
im besetzten ukrainischen Gebiet
erhalten, jenseits der Front.
Er sei dort in der Verwaltung tätig.
Man hat sie vorgewarnt:
"Vermeidet den Kontakt
mit den Frauen!"
"Wenn ihr sie zurückweist, zeigen
sie euch wegen Vergewaltigung an."
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
"Unser Held"
steht auf dem Plakat geschrieben.
Wir fahren hier jetzt
über den Fluss Selenga.
Der kommt aus der Mongolei.
Er ist rund 1'500 km lang.
Das ist der grösste Zufluss
des Baikalsees.
Der bringt am meisten Wasser
in den Baikalsee.
Der Baikal hat ca. 350 Zuflüsse
und dies ist der grösste.
Geradeaus
sehen wir den Berg der Hirsche.
Das ist ein buddhistischer,
schamanistischer, heiliger Ort.
Aber dorthin gehen wir ein andermal.
Heute haben wir andere Ziele.
Man spürt:
Lukas fühlt sich wohl in Burjatien -
in dieser Republik
mit knapp 1 Mio. Einwohnern,
wo die Russen
zwar in der Mehrheit sind,
aber die burjatische Kultur
dennoch eine zentrale Rolle spielt.
Die Burjaten
sind mehrheitlich Buddhisten.
Zwischenhalt.
Für mich der Moment,
erste Kontakte zu knüpfen.
Hier - bei
traditioneller burjatischer Küche -
erfahre ich,
dass fast jede Teilnehmerin
Verwandte oder Bekannte
an der ukrainischen Front hat.
Die erste Sehenswürdigkeit:
die buddhistische Klosteranlage
Bultumurskiy Datsan.
Der Tempel
war zu Stalins Zeiten zerstört worden
und die Priester
ermordet oder verhaftet.
Mit viel Herzblut
wurde das Kloster in den
letzten Jahren wieder aufgebaut.
Die meisten Frauen in Lukas' Gruppe
sind eigentlich keine Buddhistinnen,
aber sie machen die Rituale
gerne mit.
Und das Wasser hier soll wahre Wunder
wirken, erzählt man uns.
(Mann) Es hilft ganz sicher.
Bei vielen Krankheiten:
Magenkrebs, Dickdarmkrebs, Gastri-
tis, Magen-Darm-Trakt-Krankheiten.
Ein Kranker soll am Morgen,
am Mittag und am Abend
dieses Wasser trinken.
Man kann damit
auch Tee oder Suppe kochen.
Nach ein, zwei Monaten
geht es ihm besser.
Er läuft wieder herum
und singt Lieder.
Das sagen alle.
Marina erzählt mir von den Kämpfen,
in die ihr Schwiegersohn
verwickelt war.
Unsere Herzen werden zerrissen.
Wir verlieren unsere Söhne,
Ehemänner, Brüder.
Wie weiter?
Ich persönlich glaube an Putin.
Sein Aussehen ist sehr glaubwürdig.
Ich kenne zwar sein Team nicht,
von Politik verstehe ich wenig,
aber Putin ...
Ja, er trägt nicht umsonst
den schwarzen Judogürtel.
Sie glauben ihm?
- Ja, ich glaube ihm.
Und was hält man bei euch
von der Spezialoperation?
In der Schweiz?
Na ja, wir sind ja neutral,
aber wir machen
bei den europäischen Sanktionen mit.
Auch? Gegen Russland?
Aber warum
wird Russland jetzt gehasst?
Vielleicht
gibt es dafür ja einen Grund.
Im Westen hält man das
für einen Angriffskrieg
gegen die unabhängige Ukraine.
Die UNO hat den Angriff verurteilt
und die Schweiz hat auch zugestimmt.
Aber Waffen liefern wir nicht.
Mhm.
Mit Wagner, das war auch
eine interessante Geschichte, nicht?
Themenwechsel,
sobald es kompliziert wird.
Wenn Lukas
mit Passagieren allein spricht,
äussern sich manche kritisch.
Ich höre natürlich von vielen,
die gegen diese Situation sind.
Die meisten
können es einfach nicht verstehen.
Man versteht es nicht:
"Wieso? Wieso?"
"Wir verstehen es nicht.
Was soll das?"
Das ist so der Hauptkonsens
in dieser Situation.
Man versteht es nicht.
Dann geht die Fahrt durch
das burjatische Hinterland weiter.
Eine schöne Region - aber auch
eine der ärmsten in Russland.
Man hat halt auch
eine beachtliche Landflucht.
Es hat viele Pensionierte hier -
die nicht wegkönnen
oder nicht wegwollen.
Wer kann, geht eigentlich.
Zuerst geht man nach Ulan-Ude.
Die nächste Station ist Irkutsk.
Dann Nowosibirsk, dann Moskau.
Und die ganz Schlauen
schaffen es bis nach Europa
oder Nordamerika.
Viel ist dem Zerfall überlassen.
Das wurde verlassen
und verlottert jetzt halt einfach.
Dann hat man solche Bauruinen.
Da hatte man mal grosse Pläne ...
... und alles ging hops.
Sind es Leute aus solchen Gegenden,
die sie nehmen?
Sie kommen alle aus dieser Gegend.
Die Armee bietet da halt
auch Einkommensperspektiven.
Das war schon vor dem Krieg so.
Eine weitere
buddhistische Klosteranlage:
Tamtschinski-Dazan.
Ein bedeutendes religiöses Zentrum
des Buddhismus in Burjatien.
Hier gibt es noch Gebäude,
die den stalinistischen Terror
überstanden hatten.
Schlägt jemand auf die Trommel?
(Frau) Das Filmteam
möchte gerne die Trommel hören.
Diese Flasche
ist eigentlich fürs heilige Wasser.
Ist das Wodka?
Nein, fürs heilige Wasser natürlich.
Das heilige Wasser wird im Sommer
in leere Flaschen abgefüllt.
* Dumpfe Trommelklänge *
Skurrile Momente wechseln sich ab
mit überraschend offenen Gesprächen.
Wie ist es mit Lukas,
unserem Schweizer?
Gut.
Zufrieden?
- Ja, er ist ein interessanter Mann.
Es ist sehr interessant,
mit ihm zu sprechen.
Wir waren ja nie im Ausland.
Es interessiert uns alles -
wo, was, wie?
Es kommen ja jetzt
weniger westliche Ausländer hierher,
wegen dieser Situation.
Sind die Menschen hier in Sorge?
Ja, natürlich.
Fast aus jeder Familie
ist jemand dort hingegangen.
Auch aus Ihrer Familie?
- Ja.
Wer denn?
- Mein Schwiegersohn,
der Ehemann meiner älteren Tochter,
ein Offizier.
Und mein Bruder ist dort.
Da ist man besorgt.
- Aber natürlich.
Ständig denke ich daran,
bete, zünde Kerzen in der Kirche an.
Ich bete auch zu Hause.
Und ich helfe.
Wir haben vor Kurzem
Tarnnetze geflochten
und an die Front geschickt.
Und gibt es auch welche,
die gegen die Spezialoperation sind?
Ja, schon.
Es gibt solche, die sagen:
"Wofür soll man dort hingehen?"
"Die sollen doch ihre Probleme
dort selber lösen."
Ja.
Ja, ja, kommen sie nur.
Und in den Familien?
Gibt es da auch Diskussionen?
Es gibt Diskussionen, natürlich.
Bei der Arbeit wird diskutiert,
zu Hause wird diskutiert.
Fernsehen schauen wir
aber schon länger nicht mehr,
diese Nachrichtensendungen.
Im Fernsehen wird das eine gezeigt
und in Wirklichkeit
sieht es ganz anders aus.
Also irgendwie so.
So.
Lieber nicht weiter.
Später sagt sie mir noch,
dass drei ehemalige Mitschüler
im Krieg bereits umgekommen seien.
Dann wieder
die sibirische Gastfreundschaft,
die Lukas - und auch mir -
eigentlich so gut gefällt.
Aljona,
Würstchen mit Käse in Fladenbrot.
Sehr gut, Töchterchen.
Schenkt den Männern ein!
Nein, danke, wir sind am Steuer.
Zur Erinnerung.
Das ist unser Burjatien.
Herzlichen Dank!
Und das sind unsere typischen,
sibirischen Geschenke.
Sie müssen abends die Pinienkerne
aus den Zapfen knacken und essen.
Vielen Dank!
Was ist es? Zedern.
Das sei gut für die Manneskraft.
- Alles ist gut für die Manneskraft.
Ein wirklich schöner Tag.
Und doch spürt man:
Es ist etwas da, das uns trennt.
Ein russischer Soziologe
sprach kürzlich
vom Krieg als Elefant im Raum.
Alle sehen ihn,
aber man will ihn nicht beachten.
Meine Reise geht hier zu Ende.
Und ich kehre in die Schweiz zurück.
Aber ein paar Wochen später
reist mein russischer Kameramann
Jewgenij
nochmals nach Ulan-Ude.
Lukas hat einen schwierigen,
aber auch spannenden Besuch vor sich.
Dima, ein guter Freund von ihm -
sie nennen sich gegenseitig Brüder -,
ist freiwillig in den Krieg gezogen.
Lukas
will Dimas Mutter Nadeschda besuchen,
um Erklärungen für diese Entscheidung
zu finden.
In seinem russischen Kleinbus,
einer Buchanka -
auf Deutsch "Kastenbrot" -,
fährt er zum Baikalsee,
wo Dimas Haus ist.
Kurz vor dem Treffen
rufe ich ihn aus der Schweiz aus an.
Wie war das für dich,
als du das mitgekriegt hast?
Ja, das ist ziemlich heftig.
Er ist wirklich ein enger Freund.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass er so etwas macht.
Bist du auch etwas enttäuscht?
- Nein, enttäuscht nicht.
Ich hatte ja keine Erwartungen,
also kann ich nicht enttäuscht sein.
Aber einfach überrascht,
ich muss es so sagen.
Wirklich überrascht.
Und auch irgendwie schockiert,
als ich davon erfuhr.
Das ist nicht lustig für mich.
Ich möchte einfach wissen,
wie es ihm geht.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Dimas Mutter
wohnt nahe in einem kleinen Dorf.
Heute ist noch eine Freundin
zu Besuch.
Lukas, du bist ein Prachtkerl!
Da kann keine Frau mithalten.
Jetzt trinke ich gerne
einen Tee mit.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie das auf Russisch heisst,
aber das ist
eine typische Schweizer Spezialität.
Eigentlich mit Haselnüssen,
aber diese
haben auch Pinienkerne drin -
nach sibirischer Art.
Mmh, so lecker!
Er braucht doch keine Frau.
Wohnen Sie allein?
- Mhm.
Hast du etwas Neues von Dima gehört?
Ja, er ruft selbst an,
aber sehr selten.
Wann war das?
- Am 6.
Er hat sich verändert.
Sein Kopf ist rasiert.
Ich mache mir grosse Sorgen.
Du machst dir Sorgen?
Jetzt stell dir vor,
wie ich als Mutter mir Sorgen mache.
Und wie geht es dir
in dieser Situation?
Wie kann es mir gehen?
Ich bete nur
und hoffe auf Gottes Gnade.
(Jewgenij) Und was meinen Sie dazu?
Ich? Nun, er hat mir bis
zur letzten Minute nichts gesagt.
Er wollte mich auf seine Art
vorbereiten.
Er hatte sich schon
auf den Krieg eingestellt.
Das sind seine alten Fotos.
Er war schon immer ein Waffenfan.
Wir haben früher einmal
am Baikalsee Schiessübungen gemacht.
(Jewgenij) Waren Sie dagegen,
dass er in den Krieg zieht?
Er ist der Mann im Haus.
Da ist er.
Er hat das letzte Wort, nicht ich.
Ein junger Mann,
der sich gerade ein Haus baut
und ein gut gehendes Geschäft hat,
zieht in den Krieg.
Warum nur,
will Kameramann Jewgenij wissen.
Hatten Sie nicht den Wunsch,
Ihren Sohn davon abzuhalten,
damit er nicht in den Krieg geht?
Es gibt hier in Russland
so viel Land,
so viele Aufgaben,
die zu erledigen sind.
Warum sterben dort
so viele unserer Jungs?
Bald gibt es hier keine mehr.
Er ist nicht mehr jung.
Er ist 34.
Er hat seine Meinung.
Natürlich
war es schmerzhaft für mich.
Ich hatte Angst. Immer noch.
Ich bin sehr beunruhigt.
Aber ich verstehe ihn auch.
Er hatte ja Freunde dort.
Viele sind ums Leben gekommen.
Er fragte sich,
wie er hier ein Haus bauen kann,
wie er hier Business machen kann,
wenn seine Freunde, seine Brüder,
dort ums Leben kommen.
Aber warum?
Ich habe unterwegs hierher
viele junge Soldaten gesehen,
die hin- und herfliegen.
Und ich frage mich,
warum diese Menschen
ihre unwirtliche Heimat verlassen,
wenn es doch
noch so viel zu tun gäbe.
Warum sind sie bereit,
ihr Leben zu opfern,
um in ein fremdes Land zu gehen?
Warum finden sie hier
keine Verwendung für sich? Warum?
Die Ukraine ist kein fremdes Land.
Das ist unser Russland.
Unsere Brüder.
Wir kämpfen dort nicht
gegen die Ukrainer,
sondern
gegen die amerikanischen Besatzer.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
In einem letzten Telefonat mit Lukas
merke ich, wie er versucht,
Verständnis für die Aussagen
von Dimas Mutter aufzubringen.
Sie unterstützt das natürlich,
weil das ihr Sohn ist.
Dann muss es ja irgendwie
auch etwas Gutes bedeuten.
Man will es
nicht einfach per se ablehnen.
Es muss ja einen Grund geben,
wenn etwas passiert.
Dann kann man nicht sagen,
es sei umsonst gewesen.
Wie ist das jetzt für dich?
Wir hatten in diesem Film
ja auch das Thema ...
... der kollektiven Verantwortung.
Und dein Freund
zieht jetzt freiwillig in den Krieg.
Macht er sich in deinen Augen
schuldig?
Gut, jetzt kann man diskutieren,
was Schuld ist.
Ich finde das
ein ganz schwieriges Thema,
ob es eine kollektive Verantwortung
gibt.
Wenn man sich
die Geschichte des Landes anschaut,
die Beeinflussung durch Propaganda,
schon im Kindesalter,
finde ich das
ein verdammt schwieriges Thema.
Ja.
Und einfach auf die Strasse zu gehen
und laut zu verkünden,
dass alles scheisse sei ...
Das kann man machen, aber
wenn man die Konsequenzen kennt,
die einen erwarten,
macht man das nicht.
Ja.
Aber eben: Du sagst selber,
das sei dein Bruder.- Ja.
Dein guter Freund.
Und er zieht in einen Krieg,
den wir in der Schweiz bzw. im Westen
mehrheitlich klar verurteilen.
Ja.
Ich verurteile das eigentlich auch.
Aber mir
geht es jetzt auch nur um ihn.
Dass er gesund ...
... und munter zurückkommt,
auch ohne grosse psychische Schäden.
Ja.
Ich mag ihn trotzdem noch
als Menschen.
Ich weiss,
dass er ein guter Mensch ist.
Aber eben: Es wurde für mich
jetzt natürlich schon auch ...
... zu
einer persönlichen Angelegenheit.
Ich kann das nicht mehr
so einfach verdrängen wie früher.
Weil ich jetzt jemanden habe,
den ich sehr gut mag,
der jetzt wirklich an der Front ist.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Spasiba.
Und so geht es Lukas Achermann
hier am Baikalsee
ähnlich wie Millionen von Menschen
in ganz Russland:
Am liebsten hätten sie
gar nichts mit dem Krieg zu tun,
aber ausblenden können sie ihn nicht,
denn der Krieg durchdringt inzwischen
ihr ganzes Leben.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024